we turn out of breaking news from the
biggest abuse of power scandal in
american history
we were right and more so than we knew
thanks to a federal court filing from
flynn attorney sydney powell
we now have access to a treasure trove
of documents that should shock you to
your core
look at these text messages and notes
released today
august 11 2016 fbi agents openly
worrying about comey's crossfire
hurricane investigation into the trump
campaign
one agent remarking doing all this
election research
i think some guys some of these guys
want a clinton presidency
another worried the investigation being
steered down a rabbit hole and engaging
in conspiracy theories another writing
quote
i'm telling you man if this thing ever
gets well freedom of information
act requested uh guess what they're
going to be some tough questions asked
didn't stop them after the election
agents were so worried about the
partisan
conspiratorial nature of what they had
done with crossfire hurricane they
purchased professional
liability insurance so it turns out they
actually obtained an insurance policy
because of their implementation of the
insurance policy
that struck and paige talked about and
get this several agents were also highly
concerned about
the now infamous january 5th meeting at
the oval office between obama
biden yates clapper comey and others
that's the
memo to sell susan rice moment 14 15
days later
remember that that was the meeting where
obama biden looked for ways to set
general flynn up and by the way get
their best people on the matter
and the one agent feared the worst that
this was a political hit job writing
quote
trump was right why do we do this to
ourselves what is wrong
with these people even disgraced former
fbi director mccabe
details how odd the circumstances
surrounding the flynn case
are in a handwritten note writing open
nothing closed everything blackmail
theoretically possible
not the strongest theory meanwhile other
agents texted about the rampant leaking
surrounding the case one agent
well it's gone to be uh uh it's going to
be
somewhat on staff and other jokes i'll
resume my
duties as chief moral officer and
rectify that
as you can see there was no wrongdoing
by general flynn
they knew it they were using him turning
the screws on him in a desperate effort
to get something on president trump
first candidate trump
if they're willing to do this to an
american war hero imagine what they
would do
to you but that's just part one of our
breaking news tonight thanks to senator
graham who will join us in a moment
we now have irrefutable evidence of
massive fisa
court fraud it's worse than what we
thought as we all know by now
comey and others used steel's dirty
dossier that hillary paid for
as the bulk of evidence that even mccabe
and yates said without which they get no
fisa warrant against the trump campaign
uh to spy on them and steals dirty
russian
misinformation dossier well it had a sub
source
an intelligence primary sub source well
now we know that the sub source was not
only
unreliable the fbi knew this person
without any doubt from day one to be a
russian agent
in fact between may of 2009 and march of
2011 the fbi was investigating the
person
they knew for 10 years he was a russian
spy
that means the source of steel's dossier
was a russian spy and hillary paid for
it all
and our fbi under james comey mr higher
honor knew it the entire time
this individual was in contact with
well-known russian intel officers
reportedly very close at least one of
his co-workers
at an american think tank told the fbi
that they suspected such
a lot more details to come